[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je vais vous parler de plantes et de
planter des arbres fruitiers pour
nourrir et pour transmettre pour son
plaisir et pour le futur
je vais vous convaincre qu'il faut se
former tout au long de sa vie et que les
anges du potage du roi de versailles
sont aussi vos enjeux le premier espace
auquel louis xiv était un versailles
c'est le potager de son père louis xiii
c'est normal se nourrir se nourrir en
toute sécurité est une priorité pour le
roi et au nom du roi pour la nation il
va créer son propre jardin nourricier le
potager du roi le nouveau potager de
versailles à partir de 1678 les
impliquer structure ce jardin avec ses
murs ses terrasses et escaliers ces
arbres et ses autres plantes le potage
du roi est plus qu'un monument
historique
c'est un patrimoine vivant c'est comme
une musique qu'il faut jouer pour
qu'elle soit entendue comme une danse
qu'il faut danser pour qu'elle soit
ressenti comme un repas qu'il faut
manger pour se nourrir et ce repas il
faut le produire et pour que nous ayons
de la petit île doit avoir du goût le
potager du roi c'est un acte agricole
qui devient un paysage aujourd'hui et
c'est le cas depuis 140 ans c'est une
école qui cultive le potage du roi c'est
l'école nationale supérieure du paysage
filles de l'école nationale
d'horticulture fille de l'école centrale
de la révolution française est
aujourd'hui tous héritiers d'un projet
de production et de transmission voulue
par louis xiv est réalisé par une équipe
exceptionnelle d'artisans et d'artistes
de jardiniers et de jardin' east
les arbres fruitiers du potage du roi
ont une échelle de temps de culture qui
nous ressemble c'est une durée qui
s'échelonnent selon les espèces et les
variétés entre une quinzaine et une
centaine d'années pour que nous
puissions manger nous il faut planter et
replanter et replanter le potager du roi
pour que lui aussi perdure le jardin
nous rappelle que nous devons nous
cultiver une forme et tout au long de la
vie je vais vous raconter tout ce qu'il
faut savoir au planter un arbre fruitier
et tout ce qu'il faut savoir pour
cultiver end fruitiers et ma conclusion
je vous le propose maintenant je le
répèterai à la fin il faut s'informer et
essayer il faut planter pour ne pas se
planter
jean baptiste de la quintinie
concepteurs et premier jardinier du
potager du roi comment son gros ouvrage
instructions pour les jardins fruitiers
et potagers publié en 1690 par un abrégé
des maximes du jardinage et une
explication des termes de jardinage
avant de planter un arbre fruitier et
d'être utile d'avoir des idées claires
et raisonnables sur ses objectifs par
rapport à un site particulier au potager
du roi ces objectifs sont patrimoniaux
mais nous avons besoin nous entendre sur
les sens de ce mot il s'agit de
conserver et transmettre ainsi classé
monument historique
partie intégrante de l'ensemble du
domaine de versailles mais gérer et
valoriser de façon indépendante du
château et du parc
l'objectif de l'école nationale
supérieure du paysage et de respecter
l'esprit du projet initial produire des
fruits et des légumes de grande qualité
pour la nation former des personnes
compétentes émerveillé le visiteur ces
objectifs ne sont pas différents de ceux
que vous vous avez pour vos propres
terrains vous fournir une partie de
votre alimentation de façon durable être
un lieu où vous apprenez des choses vous
apaiser dans notre monde en surchauffe
en cohérence
vos objectifs il faut observer se
sensibiliser s'informer le potager du
roi a été construit sur un espace
marécageux dépotoir du vieux versa et
remblayer surélevé avec les sables issus
du creusement de la pièce d'eau des
suisses voisin et dont la terre
cultivable est issu du décapage des
terres agricoles du plateau de satory à
côté ce n'est pas un site naturel c'est
une introduction à l'art du paysagiste
concepteur
au potager du roi 7 ans 8 900 tombereaux
de fumier de cheval tous les ans pendant
100 ans la terre fertile le sol le sol
du potager du roi est une création
humaine et elle continue de l'être dans
nos villes et même dans nos campagnes
les soldes ont été bouleversées par nos
bâtiments et par nos routes et aussi par
notre agriculture il est nécessaire de
connaître nos sols vos sols la quintinie
incite à ce que voulaient goûter
si vous voulez savoir si votre solde
sera bon pour les fruits et les légumes
écrit-il
il faut en prendre une poignée le
mélanger avec l'eau présents sur le site
celui que vous allez utiliser pour
arroser secoué filtrer goûter
si l'eau a bon goût c'est que votre
terre est bonne faites confiance à votre
nez et à votre langue
soyez raisonnable aussi n'oubliez pas à
grandes lampées mais hume et soyez
attentifs utiliser tous vos sens car
peut-être vos sols sont pollués
après la connaissance des sols il faut
prendre conscience intéresser autant à
la météo ce qui nous amène ensuite aux
plantes et dans l'autre cas aujourd'hui
aux un fruitier pour planter des arbres
fruitiers
il faut choisir d un briquet regardez
autour de vous et prenez connaissance de
ce qui marche chez vos voisins
l'originalité est essentiel mais il ne
faut pas non plus au nom de
l'originalité ne pas avoir d'arbres
fruitiers qui pousse qui produisent qui
vous propose des fruits qui sont bons
juste et pas cher ensuite prenez du
temps pour connaître autre chose que ce
qui vous entoure immédiatement et là je
pense aux différents arbousiers à rogner
fait joie goji gumi dans le cas du
potager du roi nous avons les listes de
fruits de la quintinie au xviie siècle
nous avons aussi nice des années 10 730
bien plus courte des fruits préférés
d'un de ses successeurs le normand nous
avons les recommandations de léon
bizarre au début du 20e siècle
professeurs sur le site du potager du
roi mais les objectifs ne sont pas
identiques à chacune de ces périodes
aujourd'hui nous devons trouver les
moyens d'être durable durable avec moins
de jardinier nous devons éliminer les
traitements chimiques et toxiques qu'ils
utilisaient beaucoup au 20e siècle mais
aussi aux xviie et xviiie siècles par
des pans dans laquelle l'art scénique
que la nicotine des puissant poison
pouvait être utilisé bien évidemment le
changement climatique rend illusoire la
culture durable de plantes qui ne sont
plus adaptées je vous rappelle que les
arbres fruitiers tels que nous les
cultivons ont une durée de vie de ville
similaire à la nôtre mais c'est à dire
que la plupart des nos choix
d'aujourd'hui engage nos successeurs et
leurs successeurs aussi
le choix de l'afrique et ne peut être
fait sans des intentions concernant sa
culture comment est ce que vous allez
faire la plupart nos employés sont
reproduits de façon à sexuels et plus
précisément par greffage
cette technique qui insère une plante
dit le greffon sur une plante notre
plante dit le porte greffe permet la
reproduction à l'identique de la variété
mais à l'adaptant à votre situation
particulière si les arbres sont
reproduits par greffage la plupart ont
toutefois besoin d'une pollinisation
croisée pour porter des fruits c'est à
dire que pour que les fruits se forme
il faut que les fleurs reçoivent du
pollen d'un autre arbre de la même
espèce n'est pas de la même variété les
arbres des voisins peuvent servir mais
très souvent planté un arbre fruitier
veut dire planté plusieurs arbres
fruitiers
avez vous prévu de laisser l'arbre
poussée avec un minimum d'entretien ou
avez-vous des intentions de forme de
figures géométriques à la fois pour
avoir des fruits rapidement et pour
adapter votre arbre à une espace
spécifique à un espace contraint comme
pour jouer de la musique ou danse et où
manger ensemble il faut être attentif
il faut comprendre ce qui arrive à
l'autre donc le premier savoir pour
cultiver en afrique et c'est celui de
prendre le temps de l'observer nous ne
partons jamais 2 0 pour les employés
nous pouvons toujours déjà les observer
dans le parc d'à côté chez le voisin le
long de la route dans la forêt jean
baptiste de la quintinie lui
s'intéressait à la circulation de la
sève
il observait régulièrement les
différentes issues des arbres au
microscope qui venait d'être inventé je
ne vous suggère pas d'acheter un
microscope et de régulièrement vous
arrêtez de regarder l'hiver compter les
écailles sur les bourgeons au printemps
comptez le nombre de jours entre la
floraison et la nouaison le moment où le
fruit se forme l'été comptez le nombre
de branches qui ne porte pas de fruit
alors
je ne suis pas un obsédé du chiffre je
suis un obsédé de l'intimité des plantes
il ne s'agit pas de compléter une
feuille comptable mais de ressentir les
équilibres des plantes d'être sensible
de leur apporter l'eau qu'elles
demandent de leur apporter le soutien
qui leur permet de s'exprimer de danser
entre eux et avec vous je suis pour la
chirurgie la taille et pour les
prothèses les armatures ou d'eilat et du
fil de fer pour former et guider les
arbres fruitiers mais le savoir et l'art
de cultiver les un fruitier est moins
une question de l'intervention sur
l'arbre est plus une question de créer
l'environnement qui permet aux arbres
est en bonne santé
c'est comme pour vous et pour moi il
s'agit de chercher la bonne santé et de
prévenir la maladie avant d'être
confronté aux guérir vos besoin de
guérir
alors je suis conscient que je ne vous
propose pas une recette à suivre
je ne vous propose pas un livre de
cuisine avec une série d'ingrédients et
des gestes a répété je n'ai pas abordé
la préparation des racines à la
plantation la dimension du trou qu'il
faut faire au plus tard comment tailler
au potage du roi site historique de
l'école nationale supérieure du paysage
nous avons à faire ce que toute école
doit faire conserver ce que le passé
nous a enseigné de mieux et l'enseigné à
notre tour préparé notre adaptation aux
conditions futures car l'enjeu d'une
école et d'un site historique c'est
celui de son futur et non pas celui de
son passé
planter des arbres potage du roi c'est
une responsabilité particulière
mais finalement ce n'est pas si
différent que planter des arbres
fruitiers chez vous il s'agit de faire
de faire des essais de ne jamais arrêter
d'essayer et de toujours apprendre en
faisant merci
[Applaudissements]